The following
content is provided
under a creative
commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Last time we were
talking about binary search
and I sort of left a promise
to you which I need to pick up.
I want to remind
you, we were talking
about search, which is a very
fundamental thing that we do
in a whole lot of applications.
We want to go find
things in some data set.
And I'll remind you that we sort
of a separated out two cases.
We said if we had
an ordered list,
we could use binary search.
And we said that was log
rhythmic, took log n time where
n is the size of the list.
If it was an unordered
list, we were basically
stuck with linear search.
Got to walk through
the whole list
to see if the thing is there.
So that was of order in.
And then one of the
things that I suggested
was that if we could figure
out some way to order it,
and in particular, if we could
order it in n log n time,
and we still haven't
done that, but if we
could do that, then we
said the complexity changed
a little bit.
But it changed in a way
that I want to remind you.
And the change was,
that in this case,
if I'm doing a single
search, I've got a choice.
I could still do the linear
case, which is order n
or I could say, look, take
the list, let's sort it
and then search it.
But in that case,
we said well to sort
it was going to take n log n
time, assuming I can do that.
Once I have it sorted I can
search it in log n time,
but that's still isn't
as good as just doing n.
And this led to this
idea of amortization,
which is I need to not
only factor in the cost,
but how am I going to use it?
And typically, I'm not going
to just search once in a list,
I'm going to search
multiple times.
So if I have to do k searches,
then in the linear case,
I got to do order
n things k times.
It's order k n.
Whereas in the ordered case,
I need to get them sorted,
which is still n log n, but
then the search is only log n.
I need to do k of those.
And we suggested well
this is better than that.
This is certainly
better than that.
m plus k all times log n
is in general going to be
much better than k times n.
It depends on n
and k but obviously
as n gets big, that one
is going to be better.
And that's just a
way of reminding you
that we want to think
carefully, but what
are the things we're
trying to measure when
we talk about complexity here?
It's both the size of
the thing and how often
are we going to use it?
And there are some
trade offs, but I still
haven't said how I'm
going to get an n log
n sorting algorithm, and
that's what I want to do today.
One of the two things
I want to do today.
To set the stage for
this, let's go back just
for a second to binary search.
At the end of the lecture
I said binary search
was an example of a divide
and conquer algorithm.
Sort of an Attila the
Hun kind of approach
to doing things if you like.
So let me say -- boy, I
could have made a really bad
political joke there,
which I will forego, right.
Let's say what this actually
means, divide and conquer.
Divide and conquer says
basically do the following:
split the problem into several
sub-problems of the same type.
I'll come back in
a second to help
binary searches matches
in that, but that's
what we're going to do.
For each of those
sub-problems we're
going to solve
them independently,
and then we're going to
combine those solutions.
And it's called divide and
conquer for the obvious reason.
I'm going to divide it up into
sub-problems with the hope
that those sub-problems
get easier.
It's going to be easier
to conquer if you like,
and then I'm going
to merge them back.
Now, in the binary search
case, in some sense,
this is a little bit trivial.
What was the divide?
The divide was breaking a big
search up into half a search.
We actually threw
half of the list away
and we kept dividing it
down, until ultimately we
got something of
size one to search.
That's really easy.
The combination was also
sort of trivial in this case
because the solution
to the sub-problem
was, in fact, the solution
to the larger problem.
But there's the idea
of divide and conquer.
I'm going to use exactly that
same ideas to tackle sort.
Again, I've got an unordered
list of n elements.
I want to sort it into a
obviously a sorted list.
And that particular
algorithm is actually
a really nice algorithm
called merge sort.
And it's actually a
fairly old algorithm.
It was invented in 1945 by John
von Neumann one of the pioneers
of computer science.
And here's the idea
behind merge sort,
actually I'm going to back
into it in a funny way.
Let's assume that I could
somehow get to the stage
where I've got two sorted lists.
How much work do I have to do
to actually merge them together?
So let me give you an example.
Suppose I want to merge two
lists, and they're sorted.
Just to give you an
example, here's one list,
3121724 Here's
another list, 12430.
I haven't said how I'm going
to get those sorted lists,
but imagine I had two
sorted lists like that.
How hard is it to merge them?
Well it's pretty easy, right?
I start at the
beginning of each list,
and I say is one
less than three?
Sure.
So that says one should be the
first element in my merge list.
Now, compare the first element
in each of these lists.
Two is less than
three, so two ought
to be the next
element of the list.
And you get the idea.
What am I going to do next?
I'm going to compare
three against four.
Three is the
smallest one, and I'm
going to compare
four games twelve,
which is going to give me four.
And then what do?
I have to do twelve against
thirty, twelve is smaller,
take that out.
Seventeen against thirty,
twenty-four against thirty
And by this stage I've got
nothing left in this element,
so I just add the
rest of that list in.
Wow I can sort two lists,
so I can merge two lists.
I said it poorly.
What's the point?
How many operations did
it take me to do this?
Seven comparisons, right?
I've got eight elements.
It took me seven
comparisons, because I
can take advantage
of the fact I know
I only ever have to look at the
first element of each sub-list.
Those are the only
things I need to compare,
and when I run out of one list,
I just add the rest of the list
in.
What's the order of
complexity of merging?
I heard it somewhere
very quietly.
STUDENT: n.
PROFESSOR: Sorry, and thank you.
Linear, absolutely right?
And what's n by the way here?
What's it measuring?
STUDENT: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: In both lists, right.
So this is linear, order n and
n is this sum of the element,
or sorry, the number of
elements in each list.
I said I was going to
back my way into this.
That gives me a way
to merge things.
So here's what
merge sort would do.
Merge sort takes this idea
of divide and conquer,
and it does the
following: it says
let's divide the list in half.
There's the divide and conquer.
And let's keep dividing
each of those lists in half
until we get down to something
that's really easy to sort.
What's the simplest
thing to sort?
A list of size one, right?
So continue until we
have singleton lists.
Once I got a list
of size one they're
sorted, and then combine them.
Combine them by doing
emerge the sub-lists.
And again, you see that flavor.
I'm going to just
keep dividing it up
until I get something
really easy,
and then I'm going to combine.
And this is different
than binary search now,
the combine is going to
have to do some work.
So, I'm giving you a piece
of code that does this,
and I'm going to come
back to it in the second,
but it's up there.
But what I'd like
to do is to try
you sort sort of a
little simulation of how
this would work.
And I was going to originally
make the TAs come up here
and do it, but I don't
have enough t a's
to do a full merge sort.
So I'm hoping, so I also have
these really high-tech props.
I spent tons and tons
of department money
on them as you can see.
I hope you can see this
because I'm going to try
and simulate what
a merge sort does.
I've got eight things
I want to sort here,
and those initially start
out here at top level.
The first step is
divide them in half.
All right?
I'm not sure how
to mark it here,
remember I need to
come back there.
I'm not yet done.
What do I do?
Divide them in half again.
You know, if I had
like shells and peas
here I could make
some more money.
What do I do?
I divide them in
half one more time.
Let me cluster them
because really what I have,
sorry, separate them out.
I've gone from one
problem size eight down
to eight problems of size one.
At this stage I'm at
my singleton case.
So this is easy.
What do I do?
I merge.
And the merge is,
put them in order.
What do I do next?
Obvious thing, I merge these.
And that as we saw was
a nice linear operation.
It's fun to do it upside
down, and then one more merge
which is I take the smallest
elements of each one
until I get to where I want.
Wow aren't you impressed.
No, don't please don't
clap, not for that one.
Now let me do it a second
time to show you that --
I'm saying this poorly.
Let me say it again.
That's the general idea.
What should you see out of that?
I just kept sub-dividing
down until I
got really easy problems,
and then I combine them back.
I actually misled you
slightly there or maybe a lot,
because I did it in parallel.
In fact, let me just shuffle
these up a little bit.
Really what's going to
happen here, because this
is a sequential
computer, is that we're
going to start off up
here, at top level,
we're going to divide
into half, then
we're going to do the
complete subdivision
and merge here before we ever
come back and do this one.
We're going to do a division
here and then a division there.
At that stage we can merge
these, and then take this down,
do the division merge
and bring them back up.
Let me show you an
example by running that.
I've got a little list
I've made here called test.
Let's run merge sort on it, and
then we'll look at the code.
OK, what I would like you to
see is I've been printing out,
as I went along, actually
let's back up slightly
and look at the code.
There's merge sort.
Takes in a list.
What does it say to do?
It says check to see if
I'm in that base case.
It's the list of
length less than two.
Is it one basically?
In which case, just
return a copy the list.
That's the simple case.
Otherwise, notice
what it says to do.
It's says find the mid-point
and split the list in half.
Copy of the back end, sorry,
copy of the left side,
copy of the right side.
Run merge sort on those.
By induction, if it
does the right thing,
I'm going to get back
two lists, and I'm
going to then merge
them together.
Notice what I'm going to do.
I'm going to print here
the list if we go into it,
and print of the when we're
done and then just return that.
Merge up here.
There's a little
more code there.
I'll let you just
grok it but you
can see it's basically
doing what I did over there.
Setting up two indices
for the two sub-list,
it's just walking down,
finding the smallest element,
putting it into a new list.
When it gets to the end
of one of the lists,
it skips to the next part, and
only one of these two pieces
will get called because
only one of them
is going to have
things leftovers.
It's going to add
the other pieces in.
OK, if you look at
that then, let's
look at what happened
when we ran this.
We started off with a
call with that list.
Ah ha, split it in half.
It's going down the
left side of this.
That got split in half,
and that got split in half
until I got to a list of one.
Here's the first
list of size one.
There's the second
So I merged them.
It's now in the right order, and
that's coming from right there.
Having done that,
it goes back up
and picks the second sub-list,
which came from there.
It's a down to base
case, merges it.
When these two merges
are done, we're
basically at a
stage in that branch
where we can now merge those two
together, which gives us that,
and it goes through
the rest of it.
A really nice algorithm.
As I said, an example
of divide and conquer.
Notice here that it's different
than the binary search case.
We're certainly dividing
down, but the combination now
actually takes some work.
I'll have to actually figure out
how to put them back together.
And that's a general
thing you want
to keep in mind
when you're thinking
about designing a divide and
conquer kind of algorithm.
You really want to get the
power of dividing things up,
but if you end up doing a ton of
work at the combination stage,
you may not have
gained anything.
So you really want to
think about that trade off.
All right, having said that,
what's the complexity here?
Boy, there's a dumb question,
because I've been telling you
for the last two lectures
the complexity is n log n,
but let's see if it really is.
What's the complexity here?
If we think about it, we start
off with the problem of size n.
What do we do?
We split it into two
problems of size n over 2.
Those get split each into two
problems of size n over 4,
and we keep doing that
until we get down to a level
in this tree where we have
only singletons left over.
Once we're there, we
have to do the merge.
Notice what happens here.
We said each of the merge
operations was of order n.
But n is different.
Right?
Down here, I've just
got two things to merge,
and then I've got
things of size two
to merge and then things
of size four to merge.
But notice a trade off.
I have n operations if you
like down there of size one.
Up here I have n over two
operations of size two.
Up here I've got n over four
operations of size four.
So I always have to do
a merge of n elements.
How much time does that take?
Well, we said it, right?
Where did I put it?
Right there, order n.
So I have order n operations
at each level in the tree.
And then how many
levels deep am I?
Well, that's the divide, right?
So how many levels do I have?
Log n, because at each stage
I'm cutting the problem in half.
So I start off
with n then it's n
over two n over
four n over eight.
So I have n operations log n
times, there we go, n log n.
Took us a long
time to get there,
but it's a nice
algorithm to have.
Let me generalize this slightly.
When we get a problem,
a standard tool
to try and attack
it with is to say,
is there some way to break
this problem down into simpler,
I shouldn't say simpler, smaller
versions of the same problem.
If I can do that,
it's a good candidate
for divide and conquer.
And then the things I have to
ask is how much of a division
do I want to do?
The obvious one is
to divide it in half,
but there may be cases where
there are different divisions
you want to have take place.
The second question I want to
ask is what's the base case?
When do I get down
to a problem that's
small enough that it's
basically trivial to solve?
Here it was lists of size one.
I could have stopped at
lists of size two right.
That's an easy comparison.
Do one comparison and return one
of two possible orders on it,
but I need to decide that.
And the third thing I need to
decide is how do I combine?
You know, point out to you
in the binary search case,
combination was trivial.
The answer to the final
search was just the answer
all the way up.
Here, a little more
work, and that's
why I'll come back to that idea.
If I'm basically
just squeezing jello,
that is, I'm trying to
make the problem simpler,
but the combination turns
out to be really complex,
I've not gained anything.
So things that are good
candidates for divide
and conquer are
problems where it's
easy to figure out
how to divide down,
and the combination is
of little complexity.
It would be nice if it
was less than linear,
but linear is nice
because then I'm
going to get that n log
in kind of behavior.
And if you ask the TAs
in recitation tomorrow,
they'll tell you that you see
a lot of n log n algorithms
in computer science.
It's a very common
class of algorithms,
and it's very
useful one to have.
Now, one of the questions
we could still ask
is, right, we've got
binary search, which
has got this nice log behavior.
If we can sort things, you know,
we get this n log n behavior,
and we got a n log
n behavior overall.
But can we actually do
better in terms of searching.
I'm going to show you
one last technique.
And in fact, we're going to put
quotes around the word better,
but it does better than even
this kind of binary search,
and that's a method
called hashing.
You've actually seen hashing,
you just don't know it.
Hashing is the the
technique that's
used in Python to
represent dictionaries.
Hashing is used
when you actually
come in to Logan Airport
and Immigration or Homeland
Security checks your
picture against a database.
Hashing is used every time you
enter a password into a system.
So what in the world is hashing?
Well, let me start with
a simple little example.
Suppose I want to represent
a collection of integers.
This is an easy little example.
And I promise you that
the integers are never
going to be anything other
than between the range of zero
to nine.
OK, so it might be the
collection of one and five.
It might be two,
three, four, eight.
I mean some collection
of integers,
but I guarantee you it's
between zero and nine.
Here's the trick I can play.
I can build -- I can't count --
I could build a list with spots
for all of those elements, zero,
one, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine.
And then when I want
to create my set,
I could simply put
a one everywhere
that that integer falls.
So if I wanted to
represent, for example,
this is the set
two, six and eight,
I put a one in those slots.
This seems a little weird,
but bear with me for second,
in fact, I've given you a
little piece a code to do it,
which is the next piece
of code on the hand out.
So let's take a look
at it for second.
This little set of code here
from create insert and number.
What's create do?
It says, given a low
and a high range,
in this case it would
be zero to nine.
I'm going to build a list.
Right, you can see that little
loop going through there.
What am I doing?
I'm creating a list with just
that special symbol none in it.
So I'm building the list.
I'm returning that as my set.
And then to create
the object, I'll
simply do a set of inserts.
If I want the values two,
six and eight in there,
I would do an insert of two
into that set, an insert of six
into that set, and an insert
of eight into the set.
And what does it do?
It marks a one in
each of those spots.
Now, what did I want to do?
I wanted to check membership.
I want to do search.
Well that's simple.
Given that representation
and some value,
I just say gee is it there?
What's the order
complexity here?
I know I drive you
nuts asking questions?
What's the order
complexity here?
Quadratic, linear,
log, constant?
Any takers?
I know I have the wrong glasses
on the see hands up too, but...
STUDENT: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Who said it?
STUDENT: Constant.
PROFESSOR: Constant, why?
STUDENT: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes, thank you.
All right, it is constant.
You keep sitting back there
where I can't get to you.
Thank you very much.
It has a constant.
Remember we said
we design lists so
that the access, no matter
where it was on the list
was of constant time.
That is another way of saying
that looking up this thing here
is constant.
So this is constant
time, order one.
Come on, you know,
representing sets of integers,
this is pretty dumb.
Suppose I want to have
a set of characters.
How could I do that?
Well the idea of
a hash, in fact,
what's called a hash function
is to have some way of mapping
any kind of data into integers.
So let's look at the second
example, all right, --
I keep doing that -- this piece
of code from here to here gives
me a way of now creating
a hash table of size 256.
Ord as a built in
python representation.
There is lots of them around
that takes any character
and gives you back an integer.
In fact, just to show that
to you, if I go down here
and I type ord, sorry,
I did that wrong.
Let me try again.
We'll get to
exceptions in a second.
I give it some character.
It gives me back an
integer representing.
It looks weird.
Why is three come back
to some other thing?
That's the internal
representation
that python uses for this.
If I give it some
other character, yeah,
it would help if I could type,
give it some other character.
It gives me back
a representation.
So now here's the idea.
I build a list
256 elements long,
and I fill it up with those
special characters none.
That's what create is
going to do right here.
And then hash character takes
in any string or character,
single character,
gives me back a number.
Notice what I do.
If I want to create
a set or a sequence
representing these things, I
simply insert into that list.
It goes through and puts
ones in the right place.
And then, if I want to find
out if something's there,
I do the same thing.
But notice now, hash
is converting the input
into an integer.
So, what's the idea?
If I know what my
hash function does,
it maps, in this case
characters into a range zero
to 256, which is zero to 255,
I create a list that long,
and I simply mark things.
And my look up is
still constant.
Characters are simple.
Suppose you want to
represent sets of strings,
well you basically just
generalize the hash function.
I think one of the
classic ones for strings
is called the
Rabin-Karp algorithm.
And it's simply the
same idea that you
have a mapping from your
import into a set of integers.
Wow, OK, maybe not so wow,
but this is now constant.
This is constant time access.
So I can do searching in
constant time which is great.
Where's the penalty?
What did I trade off here?
Well I'm going to
suggest that what I did
was I really traded
space for time.
It makes me sound like an
astro physicist somehow right?
What do I mean by that?
I have constant time
access which is great,
but I paid a price, which is
I had to use up some space.
In the case of
integers it was easy.
In the case of characters, so I
have to give up a list of 256,
no big deal.
Imagine now you
want to do faces.
You've got a picture
of somebody's face,
it's a million pixels.
Each pixel has a range of
values from zero to 256.
I want to hash a face with
some function into an integer.
I may not want to do
the full range of this,
but I may decide I have to use
a lot of gigabytes of space
in order to do a trade off.
The reason I'm
showing you this is it
that this is a gain, a common
trade off in computer science.
That in many cases,
I can gain efficiency
if I'm willing to give up space.
Having said that though,
there may still be a problem,
or there ought to be a problem
that may be bugging you
slightly, which is
how do I guarantee
that my hash function takes
any input into exactly one
spot in the storage space?
The answer is I can't.
OK, in the simple
case of integers
I can, but in the case
of something more complex
like faces or fingerprints
or passwords for that matter,
it's hard to design
a hash function that
has completely even
distribution, meaning
that it takes any input into
exactly one output spot.
So what you typically do
and a hash case is you
design your code
to deal with that.
You try to design -- actually
I'm going to come back to that
in a second.
It's like you're trying to use
a hash function that spread
things out pretty evenly.
But the places you store
into in those lists
may have to themselves
have a small list in there,
and when you go to
check something,
you may have to do a linear
search through the elements
in that list.
The good news is the
elements in any one spot
in a hash table are likely to
be a small number, three, four,
five.
So the search is really easy.
You're not searching
a million things.
You're searching
three or four things,
but nonetheless, you have
to do that trade off.
The last thing I want
to say about hashes
are that they're actually
really hard to create.
There's been a lot of work
done on these over the years,
but in fact, it's pretty hard
to invent a good hash function.
So my advice to
you is, if you want
to use something was a
hash, go to a library.
Look up a good hash function.
For strings, there's
a classic set of them
that work pretty well.
For integers, there are
some real simple ones.
If there's something
more complex,
find a good hash function, but
designing a really good hash
function takes a lot of
effort because you want it
to have that even distribution.
You'd like it to have
as few duplicates
if you like in each spot in
the hash table for each one
of the things that you use.
Let me pull back
for a second then.
What have we done over the
last three or four lectures?
We've started introducing
you to classes of algorithms.
Things that I'd like
you to be able to see
are how to do some simple
complexity analysis.
Perhaps more importantly, how
to recognize a kind of algorithm
based on its properties and
know what class it belongs to.
This is a hint.
If you like, leaning
towards the next quiz,
that you oughta be
able to say that
looks like a
logarithmic algorithm
because it's got a
particular property.
That looks like an
n log n algorithm
because it has a
particular property.
And the third
thing we've done is
we've given you now a set of
sort of standard algorithms
if you like.
Brute force, just walk
through every possible case.
It works well if the
problem sizes are small.
We've had, there are a number
of variants of guess and check
or hypothesize and test, where
you try to guess the solution
and then check it and use
that to refine your search.
Successive approximation,
Newton-Raphson
was one nice
example, but there's
a whole class of things that
get closer and closer, reducing
your errors as you go along.
Divide and conquer
and actually I
guess in between there
bi-section, which is really
just a very difficult of
successive approximation,
but divide and conquer
is a class of algorithm.
These are tools that you
want in your tool box.
These are the kinds
of algorithms that you
should be able to recognize.
And what I'd like you to begin
to do is to look at a problem
and say, gee, which
kind of algorithm
is most likely to be
successful on this problem,
and map it into that case.
OK, starting next -- don't
worry I'm not going to quit 36
minutes after -- I got
one more topic for today.
But jumping ahead, I'm
going to skip in a second
now to talk about one last
linguistic thing from Python,
but I want to preface Professor
Guttag is going to pick up
next week, and what we're going
to start doing then is taking
these classes of algorithms
and start looking at much more
complex algorithms.
Things you're more likely
to use in problems.
Things like knapsack
problems as we move ahead.
But the tools you've
seen so far are really
the things that
were going to see
as we build those algorithms.
OK, I want to spend
the last portion
of this lecture doing one last
piece of linguistics stuff.
One last little thing
from Python, and that's
to talk about exceptions.
OK, you've actually
seen exceptions a lot,
you just didn't know that's what
they were, because exceptions
show up everywhere in Python.
Let me give you a
couple of examples.
I'm going to clear
some space here.
Before I type in
that expression,
I get an error, right?
So it's not defined.
But in fact, what this did
was it threw an exception.
An exception is called
a name error exception.
It says you gave me something
I didn't know how to deal.
I'm going to throw
it, or raise it,
to use the right
term to somebody
in case they can
handle it, but it's
a particular kind of exception.
I might do something like,
remind you I have test.
If I do this, try and get the
10th element of a list that's
only eight long.
I get what looks like an
error, but it's actually
throwing an exception.
The exception is right there.
It's an index
error, that is it's
trying to do something going
beyond the range of what
this thing could deal with.
OK, you say, come on, I've
seen these all the time.
Every time I type
something into my program,
it does one of
these things, right?
When we're just interacting
with idol, with the interactive
editor or sorry, interactive
environment if you like,
that's what you expect.
What's happening is
that we're typing
in something, an expression
it doesn't know how to deal.
It's raising the exception,
but is this simply
bubbling up at the top level
saying you've got a problem.
Suppose instead
you're in the middle
of some deep piece of code and
you get one of these cases.
It's kind of annoying if
it throws it all the way
back up to top level
for you to fix.
If it's truly a bug, that's
the right thing to do.
You want to catch it.
But in many cases exceptions
or things that, in fact,
you as a program designer
could have handled.
So I'm going to
distinguish in fact
between un-handled
exceptions, which
are the things that we saw
there, and handled exceptions.
I'm going to show you in a
second how to handle them,
but let's look at an example.
What do I mean by a
handled exception?
Well let's look at the
next piece of code.
OK, it's right here.
It's called read float.
We'll look at it in a second.
Let me sort of set the
stage up for this --
suppose I want to input --
I'm sorry I want you as a user
to input a floating
point number.
We talked about
things you could do
to try make sure that happens.
You could run
through a little loop
to say keep trying
until you get one.
But one of the ways I could deal
with it is what's shown here.
And what's this
little loop say to do?
This little loop says
I'm going to write
a function or procedures
that takes in two messages.
I'm going to run
through a loop, and I'm
going to request some
input, which I'm going
to read in with raw input.
I'm going to store
that into val.
And as you might
expect, I'm going
to then try and see if I can
convert that into a float.
Oh wait a minute, that's a
little different than what
we did last time, right?
Last time we checked
the type and said
if it is a float you're okay.
If not, carry on.
In this case what would happen?
Well float is going to
try and do the cohersion.
It's going to try and turn it
into a floating point number.
If it does, I'm great, right.
And I like just to return val.
If it doesn't, floats
going to throw or raise,
to use the right
term, an exception.
It's going to say something
like a type error.
In fact, let's try it over here.
I if I go over here, and
I say float of three,
it's going to do the conversion.
But if I say turn
this into a float,
ah it throws a value
error exception.
It says it's a wrong kind
of value that I've got.
So I'm going to write a
little piece of code that
says if it gives me a
float, I'm set, But if not,
I'd like to have the code
handle the exception.
And that's what this funky
try/except thing does.
This is a try/except block
and here's the flow of control
that takes place in there.
When I hit a try-block.
It's going to literally do that.
It's going to try and
execute the instructions.
If it can successfully
execute the instructions,
it's going to skip
past the except block
and just carry on with
the rest of the code.
If, however, it raises an
exception, that exception,
at least in this case where
it's a pure accept with no tags
on it, is going to get,
be like thrown directly
to the except block, and it's
going to try and execute that.
So notice what's going
to happen here, then.
If I give it something that
can be turned into a float,
I come in here,
I read the input,
if it can be turned
into a float,
I'm going to just return
the value and I'm set.
If not, it's basically
going to throw it
to this point, in which case
I'm going to print out an error
message and oh yeah, I'm
still in that while loop,
so it's going to go around.
So in fact, if I
go here and, let me
un-comment this
and run the code.
It says enter a float.
And if I give it something that
can be -- sorry, I've got, yes,
never mind the grades crap.
Where did I have that?
Let me comment that out.
Somehow it's appropriate
in the middle of my lecture
for it to say whoops at me but
that wasn't what I intended.
And we will try this again.
OK, says it says enter a float.
I give it something that can
be converted into a float,
it says fine.
I'm going to go back
and run it again though.
If I run it again, it
says enter a float.
Ah ha, it goes into that accept
portion, prints out a message,
and goes back around the
while loop to say try again.
And it's going to
keep doing this
until I give it something
that does serve as a float.
Right, so an exception
then has this format
that I can control
as a programmer.
Why would I want to use this?
Well some things I can
actually expect may happen
and I want to handle them.
The float example
is a simple one.
I'm going to
generalize in a second.
Here's a better example.
I'm writing a piece of code
that wants to input a file.
I can certainly
imagine something
that says give me
the file name, I'm
going to do something with it.
I can't guarantee that the
file may exist under that name,
but I know that's
something that might occur.
So a nice way to handle
it is to write it
as an exception
that says, here's
what I want to do
if I get the file.
But just in case the
file name is not there,
here's what I want to do
in that case to handle it.
Let me specify what the
exception should do.
In the example I
just wrote here,
this is pretty trivial, right.
OK, I'm trying to input floats.
I could generalize
this pretty nicely.
Imagine the same
kind of idea where
I want to simply say I want
to take input of anything
and try and see how to make sure
I get the right kind of thing.
I want to make it polymorphic.
Well that's pretty easy to do.
That is basically the
next example, right here.
In fact, let me
comment this one out.
I can do exactly the
same kind of thing.
Now what I'm going to try and
do is read in a set of values,
but I'm going to give a type of
value as well as the messages.
The format is the same.
I'm going to ask for
some input, and then I
am going to use that
procedure to check,
is this the right type of value.
And I'm trying to use that to
do the coercion if you like.
Same thing if it works, I'm
going to skip that, if it not,
it's going to throw
the exception.
Why is this much nice?
Well, that's a
handy piece of code.
Because imagine
I've got that now,
and I can now store that away in
some file name, input dot p y,
and import into every one
of my procedure functions,
pardon me, my files
of procedures,
because it's a standard way
of now giving me the input.
OK, so far though, I've
just shown you what
happens inside a peace a code.
It raises an exception.
It goes to that accept clause.
We don't have to use it
just inside of one place.
We can actually use
it more generally.
And that gets me to the last
example I wanted to show you.
Let me uncomment this.
Let's take a look at this code.
This looks like a
handy piece of code
to have given what we
just recently did to you.
All right, get grades.
It's a little function that's
going to say give me a file
name, and I'm going to
go off and open that up
and bind it to a local variable.
And if it's successful,
then I'd just
like to go off and do some
things like turn it into a list
so I can compute average score
or distributions or something
else.
I don't really care
what's going on here.
Notice though what I've done.
Open, it doesn't
succeed is going
to raise a particular kind of
exception called I O error.
And so I've done a little
bit different things here
which is I put the accept part
of the block with I O error.
What does that say?
It says if in the code up here
I get an exception of that sort,
I'm going to go to this
place to handle it.
On the other hand, if
I'm inside this procedure
and some other
exception is raised,
it's not tagged
by that one, it's
going to raise it up the chain.
If that procedure was called
by some other procedure it's
going to say is there an
exception block in there
that can handle that.
If not, I am going to
keep going up the chain
until eventually I
get to the top level.
And you can see that down here.
I'm going to run
this in a second.
This is just a
piece of code where
I'm going to say, gee,
if I can get the grades,
do something, if not carry on.
And if I go ahead and run this
-- now it's going to say woops,
at me.
What happened?
I'm down here and
try, I'm trying
do get grades, which is a call
to that function, which is not
bound in my computer.
That says it's in here.
It's in this try-block.
It raised an exception, but
it wasn't and I O error.
So it passes it back, past this
exception, up to this level,
which gets to that exception.
Let me say this a
little bit better then.
I can write exceptions
inside a piece of code.
Try this, if it
doesn't work I can
have an exception that catches
any error at that level.
Or I can say catch only these
kinds of errors at that level,
otherwise pass
them up the chain.
And that exception will
keep getting passed up
the chain of calls
until it either
gets to the top
level, in which case
it looks like what
you see all the time.
It looks like an error, but it
tells you what the error came
from, or it gets an exception
, it can deal with it.
OK, so the last thing
to say about this
is what's the difference between
an exception and an assert?
We introduced
asserts earlier on.
You've actually seen them
in some pieces of code,
so what's the difference
between the two of them?
Well here's my way
of describing it.
The goal of an assert,
or an assert statement,
is basically to say,
look, you can make sure
that my function is going
to give this kind of result
if you give me inputs
of a particular type.
Sorry, wrong way of saying it.
If you give me
inputs that satisfy
some particular constraints.
That was the kind
of thing you saw.
Asserts said here are
some conditions to test.
If they're true, I'm going to
let the rest of the code run.
If not, I'm going
to throw an error.
So the assertion
is basically saying
we got some
pre-conditions, those
are the clauses inside the
assert that have to be true,
and there's a post
condition. and in essence,
what the assert is saying is, or
rather the programmer is saying
using the assert is, if you
give me input that satisfies
the preconditions,
I'm guaranteeing
to you that my code is
going to give you something
that meets the post condition.
It's going to do
the right thing.
And as a consequence, as
you saw with the asserts,
if the preconditions aren't
true, it throws an error.
It goes back up the top
level saying stop operation
immediately and goes
back up the top level.
Asserts in fact are
nice in the sense
that they let you
check conditions
at debugging time
or testing time.
So you can actually use them to
see where your code is going.
An exception, when you use
an exception, basically what
you're saying is, look,
you can do anything
you want with my
function, and you
can be sure that I'm
going to tell you
if something is going wrong.
And in many cases I'm
going to handle it myself.
So as much as possible,
the exceptions
are going to try to
handle unexpected things,
actually wrong term,
you expected them,
but not what the user did.
It's going to try
to handle conditions
other than the
normal ones itself.
So you can use the
thing in anyway.
If it can't, it's going to try
and throw it to somebody else
to handle, and only
if there is no handler
for that unexpected condition,
will it come up to top level.
So, summarizing
better, assert is
something you put in
to say to the user,
make sure you're giving
me input of this type,
but I'm going to guarantee
you the rest of the code works
correctly.
Exceptions and exception
handlers are saying,
here are the odd
cases that I might see
and here's what I'd like
to do in those cases
in order to try and be
able to deal with them.
Last thing to say is why would
you want to have exceptions?
Well, let's go back to
that case of inputting
a simple little floating point.
If I'm expecting
mostly numbers in,
I can certainly try
and do the coercion.
I could have done that
just doing the coercion.
The problem is, I want
to know if, in fact, I've
got something that's not
of the form I expect.
I'm much better having
an exception get handled
at the time of input
than to let that prop --
that value rather propagate
through a whole bunch of code
until eventually it hits
an error 17 calls later,
and you have no clue
where it came from.
So the exceptions
are useful when
you want to have
the ability to say,
I expect in general
this kind of behavior,
but I do know there are some
other things that might happen
and here's what I'd like to
do in each one of those cases.
But I do want to make sure that
I don't let a value that I'm
not expecting pass through.
That goes back to that idea
of sort of discipline coding.
It's easy to have
assumptions about what
you think are going to come into
the program when you writ it.
If you really know what
they are use them as search,
but if you think there's
going to be some flexibility,
you want to prevent the user
getting trapped in a bad spot,
and exceptions as a consequence
are a good thing to use.